Hi, it's our Lady J, and I'm
here with Karin delaPeña Collison
to talk about her Nicholl
winning script Coming of Age.
Wis set in 1965 Britain,
where a 14-year-old sheltered
schoolgirl is catapulted
into the tumultuous backstage
world of the bedroom farce
tour mother stage manages.
Where she experiences
a scandalous sexual awakening.
Hello!
Hello.
I really enjoyed
reading your script.
You read it?
I did, of course,
thoroughly entertained
and went on a lovely journey.
What is the most challenging
part of writing for you?
When I get a note,
I love getting notes.
I did journalism in
one of my incarnations,
and I just thought,
“Oh, this is fantastic.”
People are saying,
“Edit that out” and I go, “Why?”
And then I realize,
“Oh, that's so much better.”
So I've always loved that.
I'm glad that you said
you love getting notes.
It's one of my favorite things
as well as long as I have
a relationship of trust with
the person who's giving the note.
Sometimes,
you do have to push back on a
note if your experience
is very specific.
I've discovered that
that my truth is more my boss
than anybody else.
Beautifully said.
It's also easier
if you present options
with saying no, I found.
You know, getting
a round of notes
and going through them all,
and one standing out is like,
I don't think that works.
But here's something else.
What about this scene?
So I have heard a lot about
the specter of the pitching.
It's really just another way
of performing as an actor.
I’m sure you'll be familiar
and comfortable with pitching
once you get the first
few out of the way.
At first, it's very nerve wracking.
Can I ask you about
a eureka moment
that you found while
working on this script
that allowed you
to break a story?
I don't think I had any big “Aha”
you know, except in terms of,
“Oh, I see how I can solve that.”
“Oh, I see another way I can go there.”
I think one of the reasons
maybe there wasn't a real eureka
moment in the script of yours
is that the characters
are developed so well.
Often when you spend
time on characters
and really give them life
and understand their backstory
and the choices that
they would make, those choices
become very easy and very clear.
When you set them all in a room,
If you have four
characters you've developed
and then you bring them all
in the room together,
you're just going to watch them
talk to each other,
and then you're going to
translate whatever
they're saying, right?
It’s true.
What went into creating
these characters?
You said part of it was based
on folks that you knew?
I started in the
family environment
of my childhood, which
was not an easy childhood.
But when I started to write,
I discovered how much joy
there was there,
and certainly that wasn't
anything that I expected.
Horowitz, the classical
pianist, once said that
“Piano shouldn't practice
more than two or three
hours a day.”
Because “It's living
that creates the artist.”
and it sounds like you've done
a lot of living in order
to bring these characters alive.
And it really reads
and it's really beautiful.
Thank you.
I really enjoyed every
moment of reading it
and chatting with you as well.
I have no doubt that you
will be very successful
and I look forward to
everything that's to come.
Thank you so much.
Take care.
She was as lovely
as I expected her to be.
I'd love to be in her presence
more and maybe, maybe
life will present
that opportunity. We'll see.